this was such a fun film
congrats on this how much did you enjoy
portraying the villain in this because
the villains are always the most fun
the working competition is in five
months i don't need you stanking up the
place
fine i'll start my own damn team then
there it is say what i never get to play
villains and i really wanted to do that
so the fact he was like a dance villain
was just like
a plus for me i let out all my steam you
know
i think as well i just hadn't really
seen a character in that
in that position um like him so
we kind of could just go to town and
sort of play a bit it was
it was really fun sabrina is such a
force she is so likable and amazing
was it hard to have to be so cruel to
her
on set it really it was i mean i wish
we always say we wish we had even more
scenes together but it was because like
we were the first two people there that
started rehearsals
and we got along so well it just kind of
felt like she was like my little sister
so he had this little bond and then
suddenly it became like
we're we're enemies you know like we
killed we ain't messing with each other
you know
we're gonna put each other down all the
way down so it was tough but also
she's so funny sabrina is such a funny
human being
so you're always laughing around her
anyway as well as liza um
so it blended to it you know it made it
a little bit easier
beyonce queen bae i pray that you make
my feet swift tomorrow
and that you make my moves have swagger
in the name of the single ladies video
in the lemonade short film
i pray growing up myself queer i did not
have any queer people to really look up
to
in media i didn't see myself reflected
on screen
and with the roles that you are choosing
how important
is it for you and how does it feel to
kind of be
a voice for so many people and have them
look up to you and what you represent
and what you're doing
it was really cool that juilliard was in
such a position of power and
i thought it was important that we got
to portray that and
everyone was really excited about that
because yeah you know we we hadn't seen
i was like you know
he's he's the leader of this not only
this dance crew but
he's the boss around this school you
know this high school and everyone knows
about it he doesn't shy away from
anything
he's got his hair he's got his clothes
like no one nobody's gonna
mess with him and i felt like that was
something important to see and
and uh and to show that um a world like
that
does exist and is is cool and it's fun
if you were going to start a dance
troupe with any celebrity
who would you invite first of all my
worker crew
i'll say that i feel like that's a given
but also who's
who are great dancers like tenache great
dancer and armani
oh i mean janet jackson would be let's
let's invite jenna jackson i'll just
shoot her a text hey jenna are you free
you'll enjoy the dance crew
like twins you know the twins let's get
them on board
text beyonce like just get my crew you
know
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos